alors bonjour à tout le monde autour de
la planète c'est dom tom canada il est
11 heures 16 minutes cinq minutes de
retard sur le mais c'était pour cause
c'était pour préparer ce lancement à
radio canada international d'une
nouvelle bande dessinée notre émission
aujourd'hui c'est comme on l'appelle un
peu comme un titre de bande dessinée
bien connu les mésaventures en bande
dessinée de rêve badaoui au pays de l'or
noir
[Rires]
mais l'imagination à marivan bonjour
paloma martinez bonjour nous avons
également nos rêves mais s'ils sont deux
ils ont l'air de techniciens de la nasa
espère équiper les deux niveaux et
rançonner on est peut-être là la loi léo
gélineau bonjour bonjour à la caméra
marie claude simard bonjour alors voilà
on est prêt le lancement de cette bande
dessinée on va vous montrer la faire
découvrir à tout le monde on a beaucoup
beaucoup d'image on a beaucoup d'invités
mais d'abord on commence par vos
premières impressions je sais que les
canadiens n'ont rien eu à faire que de
regarder des bandes dessinées lorsqu'ils
sont au travail
je vous ai envoyé hier un hyperlien sous
un embargo oui je tiens quand même à
vous dire stéphane que moi je les lui
hier soir chez moi et non pas au travail
si vous voulez on pendant que vous me
donnez vos impressions on va vous
présenter des images de cette bande
dessinée
les premières images on a plusieurs
images en voici un premier lot alors
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti en
regardant cette histoire au sujet
rappelons le de ras el badaoui en fait -
g g j'avais fait plusieurs sujets pour
rci sur un yves badaoui samson ce groupe
queen and son sinon youtube va nous a
censuré
voilà on baisse le oui c'est ça j'avais
suivi l'actualité tout ce qui entourait
raïs badaoui lorsque j'étais à rci dont
j'ai écrit plusieurs articles là dessus
et j'ai interviewé son épouse l'année
passée où il ya deux ans elle parlait un
peu moins bien français qu'aujourd'hui
mais ça avait été vraiment un grand
plaisir de la rencontrer et en lisant la
bande dessinée hier soir je retrouvais
tout ce qu'elle m'avait raconté alors
c'était vraiment intéressant
bon il ya l'histoire d'amour au début je
ne connaissais pas comment ils s'étaient
rencontrés
c'est fantastique c'est formidable la
déconvenue société en arabie saoudite
très fermé willy cloisonne les hommes et
les femmes
oui oui et c'est ça tous les détails de
leur rencontre mais aussi tous les
détails de leur vie là c'est intéressant
parce que dans la bande dessinée à la
carte alors on sait d'où ils viennent
exactement en arabie saoudite
plein de détails vraiment important pour
bien comprendre l'histoire
paloma martinez vos premières
impressions lorsque vous avez consulté
les cette bande dessinée sur le web
j'adore le titre right badaoui révéla
livet la liberté ça me fait vraiment
penser à tous ces immigrants qui
arrivent qui rêve de liberté quand ils
arrivent au canada quand ils veulent
quand ils veulent reconstruire leurs
vies se réinventer donc j'adore le titre
et puis évidemment c'est très c'est très
touchant de voir comment cette histoire
se développer qui a fait on connaît
actuellement ce qui arrive avec avec cet
homme là mais on peut tellement vous
êtes tellement
à se mettre dans ces dans sa peau et là
les images sont belles c'est bien tard
c'est très cinématographique moi j'adore
le trait de la deûle à la plate du
dessin oui et c'est en noir et blanc
donc moi je pense que ça communique
vraiment le le monde un peu le désert
jeu en plus d'être une histoire tragique
pour le moment c'est c1 le j'adore ça
moi je regardais ça comme une bande
dessinées de tintin c'est pas du tout
mon inspiration je m'inspire d'un peu
tout moi on va se tourner vers le
premier invité parce que on a aussi des
images du lancement avant de vous
présenter nos premiers invités hier
c'était le lancement radio canada à
sherbrooke c'est eux qui sont à
l'origine de cette formidable aventure
en bande dessinée de rêve badawi qui est
en prison depuis cinq ans maintenant en
arabie saoudite alors ce sont des gens
là-bas et journalistes qui se sont mis
ensemble qu'ils ont décidé de raconter
cette histoire puisqu'il faut le
rappeler la famille de ray rice bedoui a
bein oui lentement sherbrooke trois
enfants et règlements les pouilles
quel beau projet comme ça c'est à une
fondation oui est ce que vous les
regardez les images du lancement oui ça
s'appelle le vide et au lancement on a
on a enlevé le sont mais on va en
rajouter dans quelques secondes avec une
invitée spéciale à roissy vous allez sur
à cette adresse 6 1
c'est ce radio canada.ca barres obliques
badaoui voulez regarder le lancement de
ce facebook live c'est ce qu'on a vu
donc jeudi soir jeudi soir en direct sur
facebook live on voyait là une belle
initiative de radio canada à sherbrooke
est une des quatre personnes qui est
assise là c'est une de nos invités
devinez laquelle
c'est la 1re 2e 3e voie l'es2
la vidéo envoyer les jo je veux 2 les
deux ans à l'aide de vidéos
on a deux des quatre invités qui sont
avec nous aujourd'hui et la première la
voici
il s'agit de geneviève proulx
journaliste et scénariste de ce beau
projet nous allons maintenant vers skype
elle se trouve au j'imagine à sherbrooke
1 elle a pas eu le temps de voyager
bonjour et vous êtes vous avez la belle
compagnie on va augmenter votre sont
pour bien vous entendre
alors vous êtes en jeu bonjour geneviève
est ce que vous voilà on va vous
entendre bonjour c'est que je lui ai
fait un compliment sens avant qu'elle
était là en façade
oui effectivement j'ai adoré le trait de
votre de votre pinceau de votre crayon
je vais commencer par vous est ce que
vous êtes l'auteur de d'autres bandes
dessinées bien connu au québec devait
avoir beaucoup d'expérience j'ai
beaucoup puisque je faisais plus du
contractuel surtout de l'illustration
j'ai étudié la bande dessinée à l'école
interdit en fait multidisciplinaire de
l'image c'est duke university québec en
outaouais
donc j'avais déjà un bateau en bon
français de bande dessinée mais je
l'aimé pas encore utilisé à plein
potentiel
j'ai fait plusieurs collectifs mais
c'est ma première vraie bande dessinée
le professionnel donc
donc voilà vous êtes une expert vous
êtes une professionnelle qu'est ce qu'on
vous dit des gens doivent dire dans plus
de l'histoire il ya aussi commencé
raconter comment ces visualiser comment
est ce que le commun les gens réagissent
en zambie ce je sens que vous êtes là
que vous étiez là c'est comme si on est
là c'est surtout que vous n'êtes jamais
allé en arabie samedi donc ensuite les
images qu'on voit de là bas comment vous
vous êtes mis vraiment dans comment vous
vous êtes lancé dans l'histoire on ne
sachant pas en ne connaissant pas le
pays mais faut se rappeler qu'on est
trois dans la bande dessinée principal
un donc de journalisme je suis
clairement pas journaliste je vais
vraiment l'illustration de la bande
dessinée bon ça a été une super belle
quand la collaboration notamment avec
jane birkin avec moi mais aussi avec
marie-eve la cac qui m'ont beaucoup aidé
et qui m'ont aussi appuyé dans les
dessins énormément
donc on m'a vraiment aidé à trouver les
belles références visuelles
bien sûr on ne peut pas y aller donc
beaucoup d'imagés les filles ont fait un
super beau travail de recherche visuelle
d'image de vidéos
plusieurs choses qui étaient de mauvaise
qualité mais on était capable de trouver
quand même les inspirations là dedans
les descriptions aussi de lieux certains
endroits on n'avait aucun aucune
référence visuelle donc ça a été
beaucoup de weston recherche purement
visuel donc on va se tourner vers votre
collègue qui s'intéressait beaucoup à
l'aspect de scénarisation
je dois vous dire que moi je suis à
préférer impressionné par ce cette façon
différente de présenter la bande vidéo à
l'écran de l'ordinateur c'est un produit
fait pour ça pour l'internet pour le web
et là on voit l'image de votre votre
skype qui est horrible verticale
j'imagine qu'on appelle verticale sas
d'une bande une bande dessinée ordinaire
on lit cette façon verticale vous sur
l'ordinateur il ya une autre approche
est votre texte vous devez le le greffé
dans cette nouvelle façon de présenter
la fin expliquez-nous là les nouveaux
défis que vous avez pu surmonter et
crimes moi je suis journaliste web radio
canada donc c'est facile pour moi de de
tricoter longtemps ce des textes et de
parler longtemps et mon plus grand défi
ça a été de synthétiser dans des cars de
s'assurer que le texte des paroles honda
avec l'image son voisin de sarre et
triste j'ai pas besoin d'écrire un tsar
est risqué gens le savent
donc c'est un défi d'adaptation et le
myriam beaucoup aidé là dedans
des fois on aurait on refaire des cars
10 20 fois au niveau du texte pour
s'ajuster à ce que je voyais vraiment un
travail particulier c'est un super défi
justement en ce moment notre défi c'est
d'essayer de montrer des images de votre
bande dessinée telle que vue sur le web
sur les tablettes par exemple alors on a
filmé l'expérience c'est c'est comme un
test en direct de façon de le faire
alors voici ce qu'on a fini ce matin
c'est l'expérience de la personne qui se
présente à son ordinateur à ce son
sur sa tablette et qui essaie de lire ça
qui réussit à lire donc cette histoire
et je donne j'accorde quelque 7 secondes
huit secondes à chaque oui pour moi hier
soir je les écoutais justement sur ma
tablette vous avez écouté la bande
dessinée ben oui c'est nouveau c'est
l'expérience dans ma tête j'ai tout
entendu et je les lui autant en vertical
qu'horizontal oui j'ai pas de problème
en fait dans les deux sens non non plus
jeunes aux problèmes non c'est vrai mais
presque mon dynamisme et un ordinateur
ils sont mon bureau il pèse à peu près
20 kg ha oui alors écoutez je voulais
savoir geneviève on va terminer là
dessus la réaction du public du grand
public à chabot qui a soir à
radio-canada
il y avait du monde il y avait tous les
principaux intéressés il y avait
amnistié internationales ont valeur
perdait dans un instant qu'il est la
réaction du grand public j'imagine que
les courriels doivent rentrer dans un
tel projet faut pas l'oublier c'est une
première la réaction est extraordinaire
les gens sont contents de voir se former
lost informe occupé plusieurs c'est
autant aux plus jeunes qu'aux gens qui
sont moins familiers avec l'arabie
saoudite avec lesquels sont droits
humains la question politique
ça s'adresse tellement à tout le monde
tout le monde peut y trouver son compte
là on a des commentaires super
chaleureux pierre n 5 dans sa conjointe
était tellement heureuse et les enfants
également
quel super content d'en apprendre sur
l'histoire de leur pain alors qu'est ce
que j'apprends c'est que c'est aussi en
anglais donc oui puis j'ai un petit
scoop pour vous on est en développement
pour une traduction arabe et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il ya une collègue
de radio canada international qui a
participé à votre bande dessinée oui
effectivement maya boussard et bien moi
aider parce que on se rappellera que je
parle pas du tout arabe jusqu'à ce
qu'ils aient ce qui est bien là dedans
c'est que c'est l'art au service de la
politique parce qu il
message politique très fort dans tout ça
et on va en parler dans un instant avec
une invitée qui est à l'aise avec ces
questions là merci beaucoup nous avons
parlé du volet purement artistique et
exaltant de votre nouvelle aventure sur
le web
et puis à bientôt aller si vous
permettez on a beaucoup parlé de
l'épouser et sauf que qui dont le
français est un petit peu difficile
voilà pourquoi elle n'est pas à
l'émission je suis quand même elle a
reçu plusieurs appuis internationaux des
nombreux prix et reconnaissances pour
son mari en allemagne en france en
belgique en suède au danemark depuis
cinq ans qu'il est emprisonné
il n'y a pas que le canada qui fait des
pressions alors je vais vous vous on va
le se rendre au parlement européen en
2004 par notre machine à remonter le
moral
le menton le temps remontée mans voici
donc les pauses entre qui reçoit le prix
c'est pas le prix nobel de la paix mis
là été nominé pour le prix nobel de la
paix on est là on va regarder ça plein
sont s'il vous plaît elle reçoit le prix
au nom de son mari
mille merci mesdames messieurs me
alors voilà une petite panne du côté du
parlement européen aujourd'hui sont pas
vite en affaires si vous voulez on veut
mettre fin à cette vidéo vous voyez un
peu quand même à la dire mais elle a
remercié les gens il ya une minute de
silence à la demande et une minute de
silence pour mon mari s'il vous plaît je
vais me tourner vers la question tam-tam
canada cette semaine pendant que nous
effectuons notre appel vers notre
deuxième invité mystère troisième en
fait si vous faites le compte
oui alors notre question tomtom cette
semaine marie-claude vous voulez nous
l'a rappelé oui c'était quelle bande
dessinée dans votre vie vous a le plus
ouvert au monde
échangez vos perceptions anne-marie vous
avez eu le temps d'y penser à cette
question ben oui j'ai besoin de
réfléchir moi ça me prend du temps mais
une fois que j'ai trouvé c'est bon non
mais sérieusement petit j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de bandes dessinées bon parce
que c'était ça la vie
mais depuis je me suis rattrapé et une
bande dessinée que j'ai découvert il ya
quelques essais de guy delisle vous le
connaissez non guy de l'iss est un
québécois qui a fait le tour du monde en
fait pour son travail et qui s'est
retrouvé dans toutes sortes de pays et
il a décidé de raconter ces histoires là
ses présences danser dans ces pays à
travers des romans graphiques donc des
bandes dessinées et là on se retrouve
vraiment dans la réalité un peu comme
cette bande dessinée sur rise badaoui
alors guy delisle est passée par la
chine dont il a écrit shenzhen
il est allé en birmanie il a écrit ses
chroniques birmanes en corée du nord
avec pyongyang et chroniques de
jérusalem bon c'est un peu un véritable
espace louis mais c'est tellement
intéressant vous en apprenez sur la vie
dans ces pays là c'est vraiment bon
serge la marche la marche
je vais pas manquer la marche quand même
serge la marche pas le mans martinez
nous a écrit pour répondre à notre
question que les bandes la bande
dessinée qui vous a le plus ouvert au
monde et il dit qu'est-ce qu'ils tuent
serge il dit un thé et évidemment mais
j'ai trouvé martine moulin un bon voyage
à spirou et fantasio bernat prince ont
voyagé aussi pas mal
astérix et alix pour l'europe surtout le
cul lucky luke pour les états unis de
l'ouest ballet
les bagues habran voilà bon des limbes
pour l'imaginaire dans l'espace canardo
pour l'europe de l'est
je les préfère tout est d'autres pas
nommé valérian et la cité des eaux
mouvantes c'était ma bande dessinée
préférée quand j'étais un enfant c'était
un sport dans le futur vers l'avenir où
il ya un réchauffement climatique
imaginé cet écrit milan 70
on annonce déjà beaucoup new york a
emporté par les eaux et puis j'imagine
aussi on pourrait ajouter un volet
supplémentaire au sujet de miami
sébastien richard à paloma d'olive et
perso police il en profite et police je
pense effectivement persepolis il offre
un regard différent de celui colportées
par les médias populaires
sophie dumont en arrivons alors elle dit
finement de frais d'une bd ou les
lettres de l'océan atlantique sont des
îles alors maintenant on ne se posait
pas la question à moi oui ben oui mais
qu'à ma vie hélas pas marqué ma vie
parce que j'ai pas beaucoup lu de bandes
dessinées quand je te gêne comme un mali
mais plus tard je me suis intéressé au
rôle des femmes dans les bandes
dessinées mexicaine je suis donné exit
yens il ya une qui s'appelle adelita qui
a été écrite par oc et kroos et puis
adelita s est aussi le nom de ma fille
ma fille s'appelle à delhi mais je les
nommer comme ça parce que l élite
c'était les femmes révolutionnaires au
mexique
oui c'était celle qui accompagnait les
révolutionnaires connu dix sont
entraînés mais basque et c'était
toujours les sommes qui étaient dans
l'histoire puis on l'est on racontait
peu l'histoire des femmes qui
accompagnaient ces sommes à l'époque de
la pression
ma main il m'appelait lonato pour
dicaprio aurait coûté au bas mot d'air à
mireille est là car quel est son
personnage ou sa bande dessinée préférée
celle qui la plus ouverte au monde c'est
une bonne question à lui poser
puisqu'elle travaille pour amnesty
international à sherbrooke section
canadienne
bonjour mireille bonjour vous nous voyez
bien il n'y a pas de problème et bien
alors votre personnage ou votre bande
dessinée préférée
est ce que c'était un teint au pays de
l'or noir où c'était autre chose
ben moi j'ai beaucoup aimé persepolis
tenté bien cette question de leur jeune
satrapi oui mais c'est sûr que j'ai un
petit coup de coeur et sans arme en
bande dessinée qui met en scène
l'histoire de ras el badawi qui a été
trop j'étais un esprit écouter dans ce
pasteur pas seulement un coup de coeur
nouveau là c'est une histoire que vous
suivez depuis le départ quand on appelle
amnistie internationale et on veut avoir
des nouvelles de ce qui se passe au
niveau de ce prisonnier qui est écroué
depuis cinq ans on savoir quels sont les
succès jusqu'à maintenant des pressions
politiques sévères vous qu'on doit se
tourner qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire au sujet de notre prisonnier
aujourd'hui ce qu'il est en santé
d'abord les nouvelles colonnes de son
état de santé ou de son moral nous
parviennent par l'entremise de son
épouse une soif haidar qui peut lui
parler quelques semaines des courte
conversation téléphonique est allé
nautique malheureusement c'est ainsi
depuis quelques mois un rail fait de huy
est assez déprimée assez découragés
surtout depuis que la marque symbolique
du 5 ans et des patients présentent donc
ça fait déjà la moitié de sa femme qu'il
est déjà purgés et salue le courage
alors que ce que qu'est-ce que quand
même il doit y avoir des nouveaux gestes
de poser pour essayer de lui venir en
aide
iliad et bien sûr des citoyens qui se
prononce mais au niveau des
gouvernements
si on essaie de vous demander la caisse
qui ressort depuis un an au niveau des
gestes politiques de ceux qui ont osé se
prononcer malheureusement d'un autre
côté on trouve que le gouvernement
canadien est bien tirée de le passer
cette histoire nous allons rencontrer
monsieur trudeau
quelques mois et on nous assure que la
question de rêves et des ouïes est
abordé à chaque occasion
mais malheureusement il n'y a pas de
changement dans le temps ni de demande
plus clair que nous souhaitons que
l'ipad 2 wi soient libérés qu'ils
n'aimeraient pas du tout d'être en
prison et bien sûr qu'il est également
bienvenue au canada
ils vont trouver les mots qu'il faut
changer de démarcher hausse et emmène on
va présenter des images de notre ami qui
est en prison parce que bon on parle de
lui depuis tantôt on l'a vu en forme de
bande dessinée mais bien sûr il est un
être humain en chair et en os et on va
voir des images tirées notamment danis
tous deux vigiles organisé par amnesty
international voilà avec ses trois
enfants qui habite maintenant sherbrooke
donc on le voit à travers les années
récentes
quels beaux yeux une photo qui date déjà
de quelques années et puis on va
demander à mireille qu'est ce qu'on
reproche à cet homme aux allures
sympathique qu'est ce qu'on lui a
reprochées pour le condamner à cinq ans
enfin à 1000 coups de fouet et puis à
plusieurs années de prison pour le
moment un sacré bruit qu'un prisonnier
d'opinion
alors on lui reproche d'avoir porté
atteinte à la réputation bien ta d'avoir
insulté l'islam et donc il sans fin que
gêné d'opinion qui n'en fait commis
aucun crime vous savez qu'il avait le
produit ce blog libérer des vidéos
saoudien où il voulait tout simplement
discuter de sujets socio politique
religieux des sujets qui nous semblent
anodins mais qui ne sont pas du tout
adaptés en en arabie saoudite où des
libertés d'expression n'est pas permise
et c'est pour ça que simplement qu'elle
se retrouve en prison donc il mérite
vraiment d'être libéré
inconditionnellement puisqu'il n'a
commis aucun crime parce qu'il savait
qu'il est qu'il était du prenaient des
risques en fait je pense qu'ils
l'avaient ils avaient peut-être
naïvement l'impression qu'il avait le
droit d'aborder ces sujets il faut aussi
rappeler que le blog qu'il a ouvert en
bien fonctionné pendant quelques années
sans avoir de représailles et il n'était
pas sous couvert d'anonymat
donc il n'avait pas utilisé le
pseudonyme il avait utilisé son propre
nom il pensait qu'il avait le droit
d'aborder ces sujets et donc c'est
vraiment un aspect du prêt
alors que la répression à l'égard de
tout ce qui se passait sur internet dans
l'arabie saoudite et dans d autres pays
du golfe
cette répression cette taxe est
exacerbée sous peine de voir des
rébellions comme ailleurs dans le monde
arabe
et c'est là que le blog d'art ipad est
oui a été fermé et qu'il a eu des
démêlés plus grande qualité
quel impact enfin croyez vous que cette
bande dessinée aura sur l'opinion
publique
ici au canada au québec parce que ça va
être publié maintenant en anglais et en
arabe bientôt vous allez rejoindre un
public que tout à fait certainement
nouveau quel impact cela on est très
contentes appartement qu'on parle qu'on
continue de parler d'expliquer ce que je
trouve bien avec cette bd également
c'est que plutôt comme un bar d'amnesty
international qui est bien évidemment
nécessaire mais qui est très factuelle
ici on contextualise et on met des
images c'est difficile d'obtenir des
images d'arabie saoudite avec la bd ça
permet d'illustrer et ça permet de
l'humaniser davantage cette histoire en
voyant comment des enfants réagissent
comme en toute une communauté est
touchée quand un seul homme est
injustement en prison
écoutez merci de nous avoir apporté
votre vos informations aujourd'hui puis
ce qui est essentiel c'est qu'on a
découvert son histoire pour ceux qui la
connaissaient pas d'abord à travers un
message artistique et puis maintenant
bon bah on a évidemment une mission
politique qu'on ait lire en ce qui le
concerne c'est un des prisonniers
politiques les plus connus maintenant
dans le monde
merci infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation aujourd'hui mireille avouer
ouvertement vous reparler bientôt j'en
suis sûr je serai espère qu'il y aura
des développements dans cette histoire à
la prochaine alors madame elle chacun
d'amnistié internationale on a pas
terminé avec cette histoire
j'ai une surprise pour la fin oui et je
pense que ça va vous toucher énormément
parce que des gens qu'on n'a pas encore
entendu dans cette histoire mais je veux
pas vous dire autre chose d'accord je
vais simplement vous dire que à travers
notre émission tam tam c'est souvent
l'occasion de revoir ce qu'on a fait des
bons coups dans le passé voici aussi dit
il des liens avec nos histoires
précédentes et vous avez fait quelque
chose d'un peu plus d'un an qui raconte
le pouvoir pas des mots mais des deux de
l'image et démons dans la bande dessinée
effectivement il y à peu près un an
junte est revu et la blâme
comment qu'on appelle quelqu'un
l'illustratrice de bandes dessinées
emmanuel dufour qui est aussi une
anthropologue un doctorat en éducation
artistique à l'université concordia
et puis emmanuel a été là à l'origine
d'une bande dessinée qui explore les
questions d'identité de mémoire et
d'histoire des peuples autochtones au
canada
donc il a fait une étude profond et
scientifiques at par ce qui avait été
fait par le passé par d'autres bédéiste
et puis l aco jours et tout ça et puis
elle a créé une nouvelle bande dessinée
la laquelle elle parle de cette histoire
et des autochtones du pays
comme vous le savez puisque une image
vaut mille mots on va cesser de parler
on va l'écouter un bisou forme avec
cessait ses images de vidéos nous allons
la vidéo numéro 8
j'ai une histoire à raconter avec son
s'il vous plaît c'est le luxe
aujourd'hui à l'émission on ajoute le
son la vidéo et ça tourne
ce qu'on appelle les mémoires graphique
ou le roman graphique en tant que médium
le médium graphique peu
euh faciliter la rencontre et la
réconciliation des peuples autochtones
avec notre société en fait c'est le
problème au québec et au canada c'est
qu'on a une très mauvaise compréhension
de la situation puis des réalités
autochtones
puis depuis quelques années on voit au
canada comme un nouveau mouvement
d'auteur autochtone qui se met en scène
ou kiki ce qui qui veulent éduquer les
leurs mais également la population
autochtone sur leur réalité et sur leur
histoire culturelle à travers les
attraits du graphisme agréé dimanche
wynn à travers le roman graphique ou la
bd qu'on parle de mémoire graphique
c'est en fait c'est un terme qu'on
utilise parfois qui peut-être un qui
manque un peu de définition claire ou
qui peut vraiment de consensus
pour ma part je parle de la mise en
image la miss en graphisme la mise en bd
de mémoire d'un peuple ou des mémoires
personnelles mémoire collective ou
individuelle
alors voilà si vous voulez la suite
parce qu'on a coupé sa cour il demain
nous ont fait que présenter les mais les
bons coups à vous maintenant de
poursuivre la lecture et dans ce cas-ci
de regarder la bande dessinée c'est ça
s'appelle sur la page de tam-tam canada
attend dé moi que je retrouve ça parce
que je me perds donc une histoire
racontée
c'est beau c'est remarquable
notre histoire à raconter c'est celle
racontée par mon départ tôt cette
semaine et c'est également sur notre
page tomtom canada dans mon meilleur
coup ce n'est meilleur
cette semaine c'est une vidéo sur un
corps bois ou quelqu'un qui s'est
prétendu cobra québécois qui étend au
tournant du 20e siècle est allé dans
l'ouest canadien disant je vais alors on
a inventé des histoires et il a écrit
des livres le voici en quoi son nom déjà
j'avais déjà entendu cette histoire là
berne est du faux alors il a purement il
a inventé son personnage
beaucoup de gens y ont cru un fabulateur
c'est ça c'est pas le premier noël
promis qui se fait passer par un cobaye
dans notre histoire au canada
en voici une belle histoire de cow boy
ça ressemble un peu à évidemment lucky
luke l'histoire de l'écurie 20e siècle
donc c'est fait pas vraiment de berthod
la voyez que c'est un article quitterait
l'ont fait pour nous ça semble bon pour
nos internautes se sont un délice et
honda les images on peut écouter une
entrevue je suis sûr qu'on va compliquer
voilà on clique sur l'entrevue
je ne le vois fond vous fait pas
répondre ça parce que on veut que vous
aviez les découvrit retour ici en studio
maintenant je pense qu'on a eu beaucoup
de plaisir aujourd'hui
ouais tout à fait bien des affaires a
présenté jeu d'abord le dire maintenant
parce que maintenant que le sait passer
le train passer on peut souffler ces
jeux-là éprouvait de la nouvelle
technologie aujourd'hui
maliki de leonardo mais surtout ils ont
effectué plusieurs tests des fonds en
dehors des heures de travail
cette ville veut pas qu'on dise mais on
va dire oui non payés c'est sérieux
parce qu'ils essaient des nouveaux trucs
pour essayer de passer des vidéos que ça
passe mieux
ce soit plus limpide et on est vraiment
au niveau des nouvelles technologies ici
à radio canada international on indique
nous sommes en avance vous révolutionnez
sur nos collègues du secteur privé voilà
ce qui est sûr maintenant
êtes vous prête la dernière vidéo prises
ont dit au revoir à la caméra tous
ensemble la semaine prochaine on va
parler de l'automne au canada des belles
couleurs d'automne et quels sont pour
vous les plus beaux moments passés le
temps d'en parler maintenant de
réfléchir et on termine avec ça la
surprise à la fin c'est le message
envoyé par trois enfants c'était au mois
de juin
trois enfants davy demanderai pas de wii
qui avait un message à envoyer aux
premiers ministres du canada
et puis vous voyez ils sont en train de
dessiner ou c'est un peu comme une bande
dessinée au début de la vidéo enfin on a
fait un petit montage c'est sur le web
c'est disponible à vous de trouver nous
on fait que vous présent vous vous
lancez dans la bonne direction
on écoute ça à la semaine prochaine
semaine des as pas crois moi je n'ai
jamais cru que je vivrai sans toi
[Musique]
monsieur trudeau lasalle juin 2007
s'affairent à 5,1 kahn appelle t-on
qu'ils ont à nous avons vu pour la
première fois sa bru on était très
contente de vous rencontrer en personne
[Musique]
vous avez augmenté notre niveau des
sports nous avions espoir qui
reviendrait plutôt au début de la
rencontre nous étions très heureux à la
fin nous étions déçus parce qu'on
croyait que vous alliez appelé le roi de
l'arabie saoudite demande
là ça suffit on a trop attendu en est
besoin de voir notre papa j'ai trudeau
prenez le téléphone appelé le roi
d'arabie saoudite pour que nate
parviennent
[Musique]